ai ta cozinhar carro vai ficar bom para
o povo ao uol
o pessoal aqui quem fala dar que sejam
muito bem vindos aqui também é um jovem
de roupa e já tem uma coisa olha só de
cueca não sei o que farei isto é mais um
vídeo de laser é que só vocês pediram
muito mais vídeos laser portanto eu vou
fazer eu vou treinar para ter feito um
vídeo à noite mágica precisava eu tenho
uma coisa que faltou e eu não vejo agora
o que é mas quando tiver essa coisa vou
ter um vídeo muito muito louco sério
para o medo total na flecha eu acho que
falta pilha é porque eu cheguei aqui eu
já não tinha muita pilha stack ter ele é
pierre ainda pinta por lá isso elas eram
muito empolgado por curso nós vamos
tentar ter muita coisa pessoal não sei
se vocês já repararam mas eu dei em si
uma série que no canal e essa série
chama se é possível ou seja vou fazer
vários vídeos com o título é possível
fazer qualquer coisa eu já coloquei
alguns vídeos com escrito inclusive os
vídeos do cofre é com este tipo é
possível abrir um cofre sem xavi é um
exemplo se vocês quiserem virar um vídeo
é possível tentar fazer alguma coisa
comentei imaginem só vou citar um
exemplo imagine só o estímulo é possível
controlar um cofre com um trator e se
achar entretanto a torcida eu vou fazer
esse vídeo então comecei a ideia que
vocês tenham eu vou tentar fazer o que
achar interessante claro né pessoal e é
seria agora as curvas aqui no canal back
frame é possível inscrever se por aqui
muito vídeo novo e muito louco e já
sabem de 2011
[Música]
uhuuu muito rico neste vídeo
eu tô malucos a primeira coisa que vou
tentar queimar então vai ser uma bola de
tênis
embora o atentado pessoal em 321 o país
ser contra a bola de tênis bola e 31 vai
aí o pessoal de segurança acima tudo e
nunca faço isso em casa certo mas não
faz também a lei
uai embora lá 321 vai tratá fundo
olha aí já que marcos rosa queimado olha
só dá um buraco e cheira bem cheira que
o churrasco só estão a cargo da
professora é muito tóxico e se muito pax
que só viu um buraco eu vou tentar ficar
o máximo estável possível eu acho que
tem que ter um estabilizador história
sobre um cheiro muito de carro a chance
que tinha carinho que tem pelo e isso
vai ser só mais perto
ela procurou a parte exterior mas não
procuro tudo porque não consegue lá
então vamos tentar abrir com o facto de
o que tem lá venta entrou só sabem nunca
brinquei com facas em casa é muito
perigoso eu estou a brincar porque eu
sou profissional e som cientistas osman
um homem do fax 11 foi o criador viram
pessoal é não se vê nada é isso tudo
também está tudo preto lá dentro não
quer fazer mais
rodrigo próxima coisa que nós vamos
tentar ter com o nosso lazy town prático
a próxima coisa vai ser aqui opinam
ninguém dá carro na casa do brinquedo
você já sabe que vai continuar seco acha
que se faz de tudo para lá 321 vai do
laser contra carro olha isso já
consolidada muito fumo e china também
cheira cheira muito bem pessoal e itália
em barcos abriu um buraco sério só aí
olha só isso por aqui é isso aqui ok vou
tentar queimar pneu furou a 31 vai lá e
ainda está muito mais fundo
olhei pro lado e cheira muito jeito
muito curiosa estima pneu queimado de
sol mas não só
eu deito muito fundo depende da mesma
ter o pneu brutal
liddy do 11 só a próxima coisa que nós
vamos queimar é uma coisa muito perigosa
é por aí essa caixa de fósforo é isso
muito rápido 31 vai silêncio nem foi
preciso contar mais vencendo em 15 mas o
que acontece se optar por dentro de toda
a caixa meu explodir é muito forte
seguido e não fosse os normais não fosse
muito grande só vou deixar isso aqui
dentro do prazo e vamos tentar acelerar
caixa de fósforos e ver o que acontece
então pronto pessoal é tão pronto fez 21
vai eu não sei se a queima não sei muito
longe
uol o bom é isso que muito do meu é
muito potente e floriza acabei de
entregar 400 mil postos
agora cheira muito mal aqui chegarem
chuva que um sabe qual é então o pessoal
próxima coisa que nós vamos queimar só
tem aqui uma bola de pingue pongue na
bola
a lei é muito profissional dos pink a
lei existe uma coisa bastante curiosa
acerca desta bolinha eu não sei se vocês
sabem mas antigamente o homem fazia
vocês quando tem uma bola de pingue
pongue ela faz o imenso fumo mesmo muito
fundo então eu não sei se eu adotei a
bola de pingue pongue cuba e ela vai
fazer uma bomba de fumo aqui e colher de
uma bomba de fumo é mesmo uma bomba de
funk muita fumaça aqui dentro do quadro
então que eu vou fazer vou abrir a
janela claro é porque pode acontecer
uau é uma menina muito orgulho só
fugiram
o fundo já furou já foram olha só
continua no fundo comunitário eu sou
louco portanto eu vou pegar fogo esta
bola está afastado porque eu vou só
correr eu só vou correr 321 vai juntar
fogo estava muito fumo ou então não ou
então estão a deitar fumo
o ocupar o topo sul hoje eu sou como é
que está a pegar fogo
começou a cinza ea bola foi pra ficar na
prática do futebol ficou reduzir a
cinzas
i principal negócio eu acho que já não
fazem mais boas que fazem fumep rendeu a
próxima coisa que nós vamos fazer aqui é
tentar acender uma vela eu vou contar
aqui bem pra vocês
embora lá 3211 laser contra vela será
que é possível o cinema 3d
acho que vai dar pessoas a deitar muito
fundo ou então não estou funciona o
estado teria sinalizado dentro mas não
acende uma vela cai estou a apontar
directamente grupo viu tirando aplausos
não tá queima da droga em uma favela e
queimou boa aí é meu estilo o surdo
olímpico virou de luís também né
sinto meu deus cocheiro taxa fora mas
vamos aceitar essa novela eu acho que
ela não é possível ainda por cima do
vila velha e preto então vinha a ser
rápido
não eu não conseguia entender a vela só
querem o mesmo que nós laser foi agora
mas agora vem a parte melhor pessoal é
para que eu mais gosto e porque envolve
comida é claro né a próxima coisa que
nós vamos tentar deter ou o cozinhar
nesse caso faz ser o nosso blake aí foi
que o bando lúcio alexandre vai mexer
proteínas e gordura qualquer vou começar
a produzir aqui o nosso veículo
olha isso aqui quer só conseguiu jogar
um clássico é isso aí não tenho me chama
assim já não posso comer é requerido x 1
543 placas que posso comer agora quem
você vai cometer ifpb quem só quem gosta
de bené
então o nosso objetivo vai ser cozinhar
com bacon e vamos usar nosso coisa pra
isso eu duvido que eu cozinho
completamente mas pelo menos um do laser
tocar eu acho a cozinhar eu acho que sim
embora lá só vamos tentar cozinhar o
nosso mecânico laser 321 vai mundo
sentiram china cecc gostoso ea itália
mesmo cozinhar só se ele está mesmo
cozinhar eu não sei se conseguem ver aí
no centro bem ficou bem mais claro o que
quer dizer que o cozinhou ainda não
sinto o cheiro do queijo frito mas mas
quase vou tentar ficar com algum tempo
só vocês vão ouvir muito o estilo tudo
bem
olha aí tem uma pinta queimada por um
não cozinhou mesmo cozinha cozinhar só
uma coisa que eu vou fazer eu vou tentar
abrir aqui um pouco ângulo eo você vai
ser mais aberto para isso eu uso é muito
maior eu acho que não deve funcionar
assim também porque o nosso coisa
apesar de estar mais aberto pela
potência mas que ela conhece um pouco a
mesma porque eu sinto que não ó o
simples assim
assim que o táxi não ok eu vou ficar
aqui há algum tempo assim se ficar
simplesmente um minuto eu acho que
funcionando
eu acho que a funcionar como assim sua
faxineira vai cantar assinava que o frio
a sério eu já tô aqui há algum tempo a
chegar mesmo a cozinhar eu vou ficar
aqui há algum tempo eu vou continuar
aqui querer saber que bem cozinhado é
támbém frio ainda nossa era esperto tipo
a cor fica muito mais pálida mais branca
e que no centro nós já conseguimos
queimar o que já é bom é bom mas que se
programar tudo tinha que ter uma área
muito maior quando acerto próximo se eu
abrir muito ângulo consequentemente
perdi temperatura com isso então eu não
sei como é que eu posso fazer só vou
fazer alguns testes e depois volta a
tentar cozinhar carne não só então é
isso não significa que conhecidos para a
paz tenham gostado já sabem quanto o
vosso mega lá que me inspiro e cometem
coisas pra fazer com o título é possível
qualquer coisa que aqui em cima vão
perder dois vídeos bairros próximos
também podem ver se é tão bem divertido
e que mais vocês podem se inscrever aqui
no canal itamar franco que só fiquem vai
até a próxima